this is one of my favorite stories of
the year it's up there when with when
alex jones attacked me
my pillow ceo mike lindell also known to
many of us as mike pillow or simply
pillow
spent hours on our facebook page
attacking me in comments
and arguing with many of you
viewers wrote to me
and said david pillow is in the comments
on your youtube channel and he's
attacking you and he's attacking us and
he's calling people bots you have to see
this and i said wait
pillow is worth 300 million dollars he's
running a pillow business which now
sells coffee and it sells slippers and
bathrobes and all there's no way
that this guy is in my facebook comments
attacking me and my viewers is there
and indeed there is
we you might remember i interviewed this
republican candidate mark
mike cargile not long ago
and he said that there's satanic people
and there's machines that are bad
elections and all this different stuff
and guys completely unhinged and a lot
of the stuff mike pillow agrees with
check out these comments and again this
is a full-grown man worth 300 million
dollars and this is how he is spending
hours mike lindell yes david i believe
you need prayer well thanks mike i
appreciate your concern
uh mike pillow showing up and saying i
posted evidence of the voter fraud we
have to get rid of the machines over 54
countries have now been taken by the
machines
uh yeah
mike pillow continuing
um and attacking people and attacking
machines saying we need to get rid of
the voting machines california has 2.8
million more people on their voter rolls
than people that can vote of course
that's completely untrue there is no
place
no state that has more voters than more
people registered than actual legal
voters doesn't exist then mike lindell
started calling people bots he called
julia bot
he called blaken
a paid bot
he said to norm we need to get rid of
the voting machines and computers
running our elections we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines he called susie a paid bot
he said to me david why don't you check
out the evidence
well i would love to when i interviewed
him i told him to send me the evidence
after his symposium he never did mike
cargile said he would send me the
evidence he never did
mike focusing in on a guy named jay and
said i just posted evidence in this feed
we have to get rid of the machines i see
you are a paid bot what a shame
mike lindell said to nancy so sad you
are a paid bot
he called tanya a paid bot
he called john another paid bot
he said that pisa
is a paid bot
uh he said chris is a paid bot
he said ruth is a paid bot he called
otto a paid bot and to stu ray he called
him a bot with two t's which i have to
tell you i've never that's like a double
bot of some kind
then mike pillow guys remember this is
an adult
worth 300 million dollars
he started posting a link to some kind
of frank speech interview with a guy
named clint curtis who again is one of
these whistleblowers who presents no
evidence whatsoever
he then posted a link about p caps
and dennis montgomery which doesn't
actually provide any evidence of any
voter fraud whatsoever he then posted a
link to his moment of truth summit which
no one watched and then maybe most
importantly pillow saying david why
don't you have me
on your horrible show
to which i say pillow you're welcome any
time sir he's been on before i asked him
for the evidence he didn't send it he
now seems to be saying he's willing to
be back on
we are trying to get him back on and
maybe now he will give me the evidence
just a couple other posts he then posted
a link to some video called inside the
machines over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines posting over a
period of multiple hours
posting that link many many times
isn't this the strangest thing that
we've ever seen happen like when alex
jones attacked me thank your lucky stars
every day you're not dave pacman yeah
that is a freaking predator right there
right when alex jones attacked me
he did it on his own show right so he
did it for content he got something out
of it maybe at the end of his attack on
me alex jones sold you know some kind of
uh supplement or something like that
pillow is just mixing it up in the
youtube in the facebook comments with
our own viewers
i don't see what he could possibly have
to gain from this he really this makes
me think he's a true believer let me put
it that way so there it is and we
welcome pillow back on the program
absolutely anytime and hopefully that'll
be soon
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year
but you can help make a change our
sponsor hold on
makes trash and kitchen bags that are
heavy-duty plant-based non-toxic and 100
percent home compostable which means
they break down in weeks rather than
decades they don't fill up our landfills
they don't pollute our oceans their zip
seal kitchen bags come in sandwich or
gallon bag sizes to fit your needs and
the best part about hold on bags is they
work i use them at home they're just as
good as all of the name brand bags you
fill them up they stretch and they don't
break everybody uses trash bags and
freezer bags if you care about the
planet you can do something by using
hold on bags instead and it's a really
easy way to do your part to shop
plant-based bags and replace single-use
plastics all over your home go to
holdonbags.com and you'll save 20
percent with the code pacman at checkout
the link is down below